[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael rosenbom uh great guest I want
to say thank you for everyone that came
to my live podcast downtown at the
region theater I thought it went
extremely well I know we're a couple
weeks removed from that but yeah it was
great yeah we haven't really talked
about it though I know it's uh and now
we can talk about it do you think it
honestly went better than you expected
as you expected it did yes so you were
pleasantly surprised I was um yeah I
think you had a good guest for like
getting into deep stuff quick and I
think that's just hiso yeah Z was great
yeah it was um yeah it's different
because it's less intimate than this
setting obviously which is your little
Den but it still seemed inate it was
nice yeah yeah I hope you guys come to
the next one I'm trying to get one for
December so maybe we'll do one in
December had a few more dick jokes to
yeah there the dick jokes were just in
the beginning well that's that's part of
the live setting you guys were yeah we
were trying to we were amped we had to
stop talking about Dick um but thank you
for coming also um thank thank you
patrons for supporting the podcast if
you love the podcast or enjoying it you
want it to continue patreon p a o n.com
inside of you there's so many perks now
look it up patreon.com inside you join
support the podcast we appreciate it we
could couldn't do the podcast without
you um you get live um you get uh your
name shouted out every episode uh top
tiers get gift boxes from me with sign
note and I write always write something
nice
and um just a lot of perks lot of perks
YouTube lives just endless so check that
out
patreon.com inside you also inside you
online store make sure you check that
out lots of uh Smallville ship Keys
Smallville scripts Lexus scripts I sign
lunchboxes um cool merch from the show
inside of you zipup jackets are still
left we have some other shirts uh so
check that out also the talki
podcast.com you can get um some new
artwork that Tom and I signed only 50
prints of this new artist who uh these
are amazing prints so check those out on
tville podcast.com I'm on the Cameo you
could look at all the information at the
Michel rosenbom on Instagram on my link
tree and there it is all the information
Suns spin.com is my band if you want to
listen to music on Spotify love it we do
stag itss every month and I'd appreciate
if you listen to the music give it a
chance we have two albums out and uh
check it out you can also get zooms uh
on the inside of you online store with
me so do that and uh great guest today I
will say that uh Jam ly Sigler brings it
and it's it's emotional it's
beautiful and it's exactly what this
podcast is and is about um I loved
having her on here she's um she talks
about her struggles she talks about her
she's human and she had a breakdown she
talks about life um
I adore her and just think I I was this
close to maybe going on a date with her
20 years ago and just didn't work out
she chose a football player an NFL
football player over me which I
understand Mark Sanchez Mark Sanchez now
I don't understand
it no but she's she's amazing and we
goof we're we're good pals and I adore
her um so that's it that's really all I
got am I missing
anything no I don't think I'm missing
anything why don't we just climb right
into it if you like the show please
write review please uh follow us on our
handles at tville podcast on Instagram
and Facebook at tovil at inside of you
pod on Twitter at inside you podcast on
Facebook and Instagram insidey pod on
the Twitter and uh write a review we
really appreciate it and uh that's all I
have to say let's get inside of Jamie
Lynn Sigler it's my point of view you're
listening to inside out of you with
Michael Rosen
[Music]
bom inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience you do your skin looks
Flawless thanks you're in great shape
thanks you have a killer car it's a turo
you know a turo a John tuturo no it's
like a it's a rental car service where
you can they'll they'll literally meet
you with the airport and just do the
exchange and give you the keys and you
can take it for as many days as you want
and it's not that how it how do you
return it they meet you wherever either
at the airport or you leave it with the
key on the tire somewhere and they'll
pick it up is it designed just for
airport thing no I've I had one in
Albuquerque once and they just told me a
corner of the street that it would be on
and I took an Uber there and the key was
on the tire are you doing a SP an ad
right now A read for them I wish I was
why don't you ask them to be a sponsor
why don't you ask this is isn't my show
well I mean I I could reach out yeah
that's a turo that's not mine it's a
turo it's somebody else's car turo T the
car is called a turo the app is called
turo the company guys I'm not very
bright today I didn't get a lot of sleep
um that's always my excuse I don't get a
lot of sleep do you sleep well mhm you
do MH
why um I I need it I need my sleep to
function yeah um I don't do anything
also I have kids I'm
tired uh by that time that bedtime rolls
around and maybe I'm just like I have a
clear conscience yeah maybe you know
maybe you're just okay with everything
maybe your your your stress levels have
gone down exponentially do you think
that's the case I mean it varies life
life goes you know in cycles and Seasons
but for the most
part I've done a lot of work like over
the
last five years in particular I think
like a lot of work on myself and I think
that you get to this point where you
start to see it paying off and it's nice
it's not not to say that I'm without
troubles and hardships and M in fact
just two week ago I had a mini breakdown
with my girlfriends but like really it
what was that like what where was where
did it happen um did you
call no it was it was a
intentional meeting per se of of friends
of like we're going to get together and
kind of you
know work through our [__] and be there
for each other in a moment like kind you
know just with a lot of intention and
love and um but without any expectation
of kind of what it's going to be and uh
it turned out being a moment where I
really realized that I needed to have a
mental breakdown I had been holding in
and holding things together for so long
and you know so I have MS and I've had
it for 23 years almost and for much of
my journey I've been applauded and
celebrated for how strong I am with it
and I appreciate that and I can also
appreciate it about myself like how I've
dealt with it but I also think it's been
to a fault sometimes
because a lot of my being strong was
just kind of not expressing how hard it
is sometimes and being like I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay I'm okay no wor it's fine
it's fine and it it was a moment of like
it bubbling over and just I needed to
kind of say all the things that that I
was afraid to say which is this sucks
and I'm angry and I'm upset and I'm sad
and this feels unfair and I don't know
what I did to deserve this and I'm
really bummed and it was a beautiful
release and it in if anything it almost
like opened Pandora's Box a little bit
that for like the next week and a half I
was just a lot of things were just
coming out and up and out and I just
tried to breathe through and welcome
them but also
it was a moment of me I always knew my
friends were there for me and I had this
incredible support system but like a
moment of like when you look around at
like some of your closest girlfriends
and them like begging you to give them
your [__] it was a moment of like me
really understanding how incredibly
supported I am and that like if I fall
apart there's like a lot of people there
that will catch me but even so when
you're going through a hard time your
friends
all of our friends if we're lucky enough
will say hey whatever you need I'm here
how are you what can I do what can I do
and I I'm never one to really ask for
help or for and
so but there comes a time when we all
hit a wall and I've had those moments
like you talk about and then you kind of
just go I [__] need help and people
are like whoa hang on a second you know
that's a little jarring for people so
your friends who are always like yeah
whatever you need whatever you need and
you're like strong strong one day you're
just like I'm not [__] strong I'm not
strong right now I'm not strong and
that's why I need you and this is why
I'm having this breakdown so it's like
you just never know I mean it's it's
scary being vulnerable it's scary being
like asking for but it's also beautiful
that's why we're here because people
love to be of service and help for
people they love for people that they
love not for people they don't right you
know well yeah well then that's when it
can be exhausting but it's a beautiful
human exchange it's if not one of the
greatest ones I mean it's all love it's
it's just it's but like you said it's
really hard to ask for help you just
assume everybody's got their own [__]
who wants my [__] on top of it but it
was a moment of me realizing
like giving me an hour of time to just
share is not a burden on anyone you know
what I mean it's it's a moment that
changed my life in that moment it really
did and this was how long ago two weeks
ago a week ago a week and a half ago and
you have your friend here introduce your
friend yeah my friend Becca toin one of
my best friends one of the beautiful
women that was there receiving me and
being there for me yeah we don't have a
microphone on her but um we wish we did
she's a great advice giver you are huh
but she has a podcast called the lady
gang and if you if you want to hear some
of that oh yeah all right I'll check out
the lady gang we should all check out
the lady gang that's right you already
said she has a big following right huge
really huge does what does it mean it
means all right means hey you're doing
something right I'd like to know what
that is she's a great Giver of advice
she really is and a great listener when
you say mental breakdown I think I
think yelling and screaming and
emotional and I can't [__] no I can't
you know like just to the point where
everyone's just like we should you know
restrain her or something that's exactly
what it was and I've never had one in my
life I in that Mo I realized that like
even as a child like I expressing those
emotions my parents were never able to
receive that they were not in a place in
their lives to allow me to do that so I
was always the good girl I was always
told to you know put on your lipstick
and say everything's fine mind so that
was the first time that I've really I
mean I think I've had like little
eruptions here and there but to that
extent never and you never done this in
front of your
husband I mean he's probably seen me
tantrum for a moment but he hasn't seen
you over the edge no and and it was
actually to a point
where it was bubbling over in our
relationship because he has a lot of
anger for what I deal with because he
has a FR R seat every day and I'm not a
complainer I don't say anything but he
sees me grip my teeth and he sees me
push through and on one hand he's proud
of me but on another hand he hates it
like he hates does he get emotional
about it at all not emotional
but I think it manifests in ways for him
like it makes his anxiety worse um I
think it makes
him more short- tempered with our kids
yeah um I think that it it it manifests
in other ways he never means to direct
it at me and never really does but I
think
that a lot of my bubbling over was also
like feeling him where you know it is it
is a factor in our relationship like we
had a talk just the other night where I
think this moment a week and a half ago
we keep talking about really helped
where he was he was angry about
something and I was angry about
something and if it felt like we were
taking it out on each other and I I
literally just said to him I'm not angry
at you I'm just angry at this situation
right now and he was like oh yeah me too
and it was like huh and then we cuddled
and watched Breaking Bad you know but it
was like it was
that that release allowed us to kind of
place our feelings a little bit better
because when before that it was hard to
understand what was about what does that
make sense yeah I also think that
there's probably look I'm speaking out
of place here but I think if I had you
know Ms or something and I've had a lot
of surgeries and things but that's not
Ms but like but still IAL I deal with
pain and stuff but what I'm saying it's
not that I'm just thinking like I If you
have something like that and you're
dealing with it all the
time do you sort of think I don't want
them to like not be here or run away or
scare people off or I just want to try
to do everything myself which is not a
good thing like not giving help you know
not asking for help not and just saying
no I'm I got this I'm tough yeah I want
to show you that I got this where as you
should ask for help when needed but you
know what I mean does that make sense at
all yeah I think it's actually
more it's been an evolution for me over
like of the emotional journey and like
experience with this far exceeds the
physical one with Ms um but I think it's
like I'm now at this point where I'm
still processing a lot of like shame I
have around it and like embarrassment of
what of how it's affected me like I it I
hid it for so long and
then I I don't like using the wheelchair
in the
airport I like put my hat down all the
way inside of you is brought to you by
prize picks this is the most fun I'm
having all season Ryan prize picks right
you're doing it I'm doing it and uh my
fantasy football team is not very good
so this is a great answer for that I am
winning things now finally what's fun is
you choose two players you could also
choose six depending on how much you
want to win and I have won and I don't
know much about sports but like for
instance I chose Dak Prescott of the
Dallas Cowboys in a game and another
quarterback from a different game and I
said are they going to get more than 200
pass yards or less and I put less or
more and that's it it's exciting to
watch games now going oh come on one
more pass and I'll win 50 bucks and I
started noticing I I sent you didn't I
show you I was like win win win win and
you know I know nothing
but even if if you know more you're
you're probably going to do a lot better
prize picks is the most fun I'm having
uh winning up to 25 times my money this
football season you just select two or
more players pick more or less on their
projected stats and place your entry
it's simple you don't have to really
know anything testing my skills and
prize picks this football season is the
most exciting way to play daily fantasy
sports if you have the skills you can
turn 10 into 250 with just a few taps or
if you're like me you can do it with no
skill price picks is really simple to
play I can pick my picks and submit my
entry in less than 60 seconds uh it's
actually like 10 seconds that's how fast
it is quick withdrawals easy gameplay
with an enormous selection of players
and stats are what make prize picks the
number one daily fantasy sports apps
price pick offers weekly promotions that
can lead to Big payouts like taco
Tuesday each Tuesday price pick
discounts select player projections up
to 25% to provide even more value prize
pick now offers Apple pay for quick and
easy deposits into your account this
football season and guess what even if
you're not a football fan I like to do
hockey I like to pick on hockey so is
this goalie GNA get more than 30 saves I
don't think so I think he's kind of
crappy it's a lot of fun guys I'm not
going to lie to you and I will continue
doing this with the prize picks reboot
policy your entries stay in play even if
one of your players gets injured for pro
football games and college football top
25 matchups if you have a player who
exits the game in the first half and
does not return in the second that
player is rebooted prize picks is the
only daily fantasy sports platform with
injury insurance and that has happened
to me and I still won with having
someone injured so I am here to tell you
it works go to
prize.com
SL inside and use code inside for a
first deposit match up to $100
must be present in certain States visit
prize.com for restrictions and details
prize.com inside use code inside for a
first deposit match up to
$100 today's sponsor neutr sense.com
uses a CGM right here under my arm which
is a small device that provides
real-time feedback on how your body
responds to the foods that you're eating
your exercise stress and even your sleep
now this is something that look guys if
you see I'm wearing it I wearing my
glucose
monitor because I have found out I'm I'm
going to get into this so just give me a
second uh
nutrients really monitors my glucose
levels so when I find myself crashing
tired you can just take your phone
because there's an app I put it under my
arm the sensor retrieves all the
information and it shows my glucose
levels for the last x amount of hours
and I go wow I spiked here well that's
cuz you had three root beers dude maybe
you shouldn't be having so much root
beer maybe you should keep your glucose
levels at a even place so you feel
healthier you feel better you feel have
more energy um you know it's not just
for people who are you know I guess
diabetic or whatever it's for people who
want to live a healthier life and that's
what's happened to me I didn't know what
this was and neutri sense changed my
mind on this whole
uh outlook on on on health um Nutri
sense helps you analyze your glucose
levels in real time in response to food
exercise stress and sleep Nutri sense
includes one month of free board
certified nutritionist guidance and
support uh it really is awesome Ryan if
you want me to get you one um you could
your your life
it's it shows you what you're eating and
and and you're doing you can monitor all
that you take notes on this and it's
just so easy to say okay I remember I
crashed right I was really tired at 2:00
why well right here it says well you
spiked and you crashed and this is why
this happens and if you're if you like
if you work and you're doing all these
things you need more energy you monitor
your
glucose and it's just amazing my
nutritionist helped me interpret the
data and promptly answered all my
question questions Patrick thank you
Patrick over at neutri sense I said well
what are these see how it spikes here
and spikes here well well what exactly
are you eating and drinking Michael and
they you know we managed it and I said
well what's what are better things I
could have in my diet that I can get
some energy but won't crash and so he
sent me a list of things so it really is
wonderful in in just the short time that
I've done this I've noticed better sleep
I've noticed uh sustained energy less
brain fog it's because I'm not doing
eating all those bad things I'm not
having all that sugar and it's really
help me and you know I'm 51 and I no
matter how old you are you want to have
sustained energy throughout the day and
right now visit nutr sense.com
inside to save $30 and get one month of
free nutritionist support that's neutr
sense.com
inside you don't want people to see you
no if I hurt my knee skiing and and I'd
have no problem using the wheelchair
because I'm like I'm hurt and I need
this for support I don't know why I
still have like this this issue with
that this like shame issue like I only
just started bringing a walking stick
and a cane out with me every once in a
while I should probably bring it out all
the time because it helps me greatly and
I don't it it it happens the energy I
need to use Mental energy to balance and
and navigate life but like I had it's
not really about anyone else it's like
about me I feel like I've been like
fighting this and trying to beat it and
stay on top of it and to feel like [__]
I need a cane sometimes it's it feels
like I failed a little bit and I and I
also I'm just like with this business
I'm like worried that people aren't
going to want to hire me because I I did
that I walk this way and I used this
cane but I will say I had this job the
past two years they had cast me for just
like three or four episode
Arc and we didn't my character didn't
have MS in it so they worked around and
in fact they built this rig my character
was supposed to run from somebody in the
woods and they built this rig where I
was sitting on it you just see my upper
body moving and they just had the camera
there so it looked like I was running
worked it was really cool wow um but
then they made me a
regular and it was the first moment for
me to be like oh like like maybe this
doesn't matter people still want me oh
like I still have talent it it was
getting so blurry and so messy and
so heartbreaking for a while um and so
what that job
did was a make me fall in love with
acting again because they were I when I
would show up to work the first ad had a
conversation with the director before I
got there each episode where they were
like this is what you can do this is
what she can't it's better if you block
it this way so like I didn't have to
have this awkward conversation every
time and it was so beautiful and so
supportive but what it did was now put
me in this place where I'm like I don't
want to hide it my next
job I would love to just move how I move
and have it be part of it because maybe
it'll add something to the story it
doesn't have to be about it my whole
life is not about Ms why can't she be a
normal person who happens to have MS who
is convicted of murder that's right
that's right people MS can be [__]
too oh you could you can murder that's
right I actually would love to play a
really complicated like not love to
murder yeah why not never done that
actually no I did in Big Sky um but yeah
I think that in the past couple of years
I'm
like letting it go
accepting yeah because you know except
the shame thing could be twofold it
could also be part of you going hey I
just really don't want to be recognized
right now which is you know in general
people wear a hat or they're just kind
of like you know sometimes I'm the
airport and not that I get mobbed but
sometimes I'm just like tired I just hat
and sunglasses and just not and just
disappear so that's like you know I'm
having a tough time I you know I'm in a
wheelchair I'm tired I I don't want I
just don't want to [__] deal with it
yeah so you know maybe it's not all
shame like you know I can't do these
things and but you
know it's not even about being famous I
I it's no no it's like I don't know I'm
just being honest you know it's because
I I in
my meeting other people that live with
MS and chronic illness and you know what
in general I just feel like the more
that I
am being more honest with myself about
my feelings and talking about these
things like like sometimes you think the
more specific you get the more like
distant it's going to be then people AR
going to understand but I'm finding like
the more specific I get the more
Universal it actually is and like
everybody's everybody's got something I
live with my shame and my [__] out you
see it and I that's where I'm grateful
for it because it's really opened me up
it I can't hide from it people ask me
about it and then we have to have I had
the most beautiful Exchange with a TSA
guy the other day really yeah where I
was getting the wheelchair through
security and he was like Meadow and I'm
like yeah and he's like what's going on
and I'm like oh I have MS this you know
makes my life easier through the airport
this and that and then we just started
talking and he said to me he's like you
know I really appreciate you opening up
to me right now he's like having nothing
to do with what you've done and what you
do like you're a really beautiful person
like and I and I just started crying I'm
like thank you for seeing me but without
this I don't know if we would have had
that conversation do you know what I
mean like I feel like it's cracked me
open I see what you're saying in a way
and I think I try not to find like a
spiritual meaning and everything in life
cuz I think sometimes that can like make
it overwhelming life overwhelming
sometimes things just happen but I do
think that bigger things happen in our
lives as Catalyst for us to really grow
and I think
that maybe there would have been
something else but without Ms in my life
I don't I don't know where I'd
be wow I would like a life without it
though sure I would at this point do you
talk to well first of all do you have
any friends or family who just get
really emotional all the time when
you're around my mom she no matter what
if you're having trouble walking she's
she loses it hysterical and what do you
say Mom what do you say it's okay
it's okay do you ever cry with her
sometimes sometimes I try not to I try
not to yeah yeah yeah it's mainly with
her what about with other people who are
dealing with Ms yeah are you an advocate
like are you talking to people are you
are you Christine Applegate is a really
good friend of mine yeah I was just with
her this
morning she you know we have this like
Beautiful Exchange we talk about where
she feels like I'm like her life
but I also have experience but she also
gives me permission to be like this
[__] sucks cuz she's not afraid to
say that and I diagnosed a couple years
ago right and and she has she had it for
a while or is it something that she's
only had it for it just started I'm not
sure I think it just it like there were
symptoms that were coming on and you
know she she figured out fairly quickly
from what I understand yeah and she's
sort of like hey what what's going to
Happ what go what happens first what's
the initial like dides she ask you a lot
of question questions like that we did
yeah we had an initial conversation but
like I'm not an I live with it I'm not
an expert it affects all of us very
differently but I think what it helps is
just to have somebody that understands
and gets it yeah but if somebody had Co
and I had it go hey what happens when
you got coid what what what what can I
expect well some people you know I'd be
always like I'd be you know racking your
brain and and all that stuff but oh yeah
we've had those conversations for sure
for sure um but we also have we also
talk about Bravo a lot because we both
like to watch Bravo what do you watch on
Bravo most of the
housewives most of the houses like the
winter house the summer house I don't
know anything about that all I know is I
saw something with you just recently how
they said gandal James gandal had sex
with a housewife what the hell was that
yeah this housewife on Jersey like do
you believe her sure I mean it but it
was like it was a hundred years ago you
know they were in their 20 she was a
housewife then
no Housewives didn't exist back then
that's what I'm saying she wasn't even a
wife probably simpler times yeah simpler
times so how did you respond you're like
okay I mean I don't know I think it's
disrespectful when somebody's no longer
living and like to their wife like yeah
I felt protective I didn't like it yeah
you're like shut up yeah shut up Jen
Sheffer is that who it was I think
that's her name Jen Sheffer housewi
Housewives of what Jersey Jersey
Housewives what Housewives is the best
cuz you got Orange County you got New
Jersey
my personal Vegas girls in there not yet
there's no Vegas Housewives no Vegas uh
my personal favorite is the OG New
York original ganger OG New York because
those were the Upper East Side Rich
[__] that are cooky and wild and they
were actually friends like they actually
knew each other it wasn't an assembled
cast of women that you kind of put
together that that if I had to pick my
favorite would be like I'm even going
back to like this means nothing to you
but like Alex and Simon and you know
like Ramona Sonia Jill
Bethany this show is sponsored by better
help Ryan you ever feel like your brain
is getting in the way of living your
best life all the time yeah I would say
so like you know what you should do
what's good for you but you you just
can't seem to do it oh yeah yeah therapy
helps you figure figure out what's
holding you back so your brain can work
for you instead of against you and this
is what happens with um therapy you're
you have all these things bottled up and
you need to let them out and you need to
talk to a professional it really really
helps therapy is a great way to learn
positive coping skills and how to set
boundaries it empowers you to be the
best version of
yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute it's so easy even I can do
it then you get matched with a licensed
therapist switch therapist anytime for
no additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like no
I want to try someone else it's easy
just like that betterhelp is truly the
best way to make your brain your friend
give it a try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's better help h e lp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by discover if you like using debit over
credit don't you think it's time you
also get rewarded well now you can with
discover cashback debit it's a checking
account that rewards everyone with cash
back on everyday purchases plus there
are no fees period we're talking date
nights thrifting the latest trends
nights out with your friends friends and
it's now earning you cash back with
discover cashback debit check out
eligibility and terms at discover.com
cashback debit Discover Bank member
FDIC what about the one that was married
to uh Kelsey gramar Camille Camille look
those were the hey days of Beverly Hills
too those were great those were great is
there like a lot of sex in those shows
sometimes sometimes a sex sometimes
there's like a sexy couple within like
the cast like a couple that just like
just likes to talk about their sex life
a lot and they're just doing it all the
time and there's another couple right
now in New York that talks about how
they haven't had sex in a year and a
half since they had their babies oh my
God year and a half no sex it's a long
time let me ask you this is this true I
heard somewhere that if a man watches
his wife give birth and he's staring at
the vag vagina thank you yeah that if he
watches it some men will like be turned
off forever be turned off forever is
that true my husband stared at a corner
like of the room hyperventilating what
about your husband I had to surrogate
because I was worried about this just
kidding but I could see I yeah I could
see cutter being cutter did not want to
look oh yeah at all yeah good for cutter
I had my friend Stephanie there like
putting her hand in my vagina touching
his head as he's
crowning come again yeah she put her
head she said you I remember the doctor
asked me do you want to reach down and
touch his head and I said no but my
friend Stephie was coming out I will oh
yeah crowning reach out in
touch a baby's head yeah as it comes
done having babies but I would have
given you that opportunity if you wanted
Michael my births were parties wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute did
you what opportunity to touch a head at
the crowning is that something you'd be
interested in I I don't even know how
the hell that would happen
that's you can YouTube it really I I I
don't know I mean if you know if I was
with someone and they want me to be
there I would be there but I don't think
I need to see it I be look in her eyes
and breathe with her and I love you I'm
here for you I don't care if you fart or
whatever things happen look she's
probably [__] on the table is what
probably I'll wear a mask and uh and
then it happens and I'll look down I go
oh there's the kid oh yeah look that's
our baby that's came out of your vagina
I didn't see it but I assume it happened
yes that's that's probably the move yeah
so cutter didn't do it no no probably
glad for sure he didn't need to be there
I mean it's nice if a guy could do it I
mean some women will be out there going
how could that's a beautiful thing no no
I'm I'm not pressuring him into doing
that
no no all right so you're watching Bravo
I feel um like for better or worse like
very disconnected from this business now
really I do I do does cutter like
sometimes I'm like is this bad like I
like I forget that I'm like an actress
sometimes do your agents check in with
you yes do they say hey we're looking
into some stuff there might be this are
you still yeah I also think that I used
to stress so much about my career I used
to stress so much and put so much value
on myself and if I H had work or not and
I really don't
anymore I really don't it's I love it
still I know I still want to do it but
it's
really it's not that it's less valuable
to me or important but it's just not
everything anymore I don't know if it's
just getting into my 40s or what it is
but there was just a big shift for me
about it I don't feel like I have
anything to prove you don't I but no one
does you know what I mean that's the
thing everyone look if you're doing this
if you're in a in in something because
you want to prove yourself and you want
to you want Daddy to be happy and you
want all these then it's you're not
doing it for the right reasons you you
have to at some point go hey who am I
doing this for and if you're not doing
it for yourself who you doing it for
yeah did we talk about this last time we
went here where like I kind of quit for
a little while and then I went qu for a
little while too I mean with exception
of the little things here and there but
like yeah it just it didn't appeal to me
it was just um but now I'm getting you
know the flow a little bit in terms of
like the juic is Flowing but I don't
know yet it has to be the right thing
can we manifest a job together we would
have so much fun oh my God we would have
so much fun yeah there's something about
you like whenever I'm with you you bring
out like you know there's just people
that bring out like sides of you you
bring out a very playful side of me I do
you do probably cuz we met doing game
nights together probably yeah yeah and
you know how had to crush on you I know
you
cutter it was a long time ago many you
have children now you didn't look the
you adorable in the way you had hit on
me yeah yeah I was never
like put off by it no I playful and then
like hey we should maybe hang out
sometime if you're I for I think I was
dating somebody by the time you a guy
named Mark
Sanchez because I uh the Jets guy he
just gave a look like what no but like I
remember just going
um you know hey you know it'll be nice
to hang out she's like well I'm sort of
dating somebody right now oh [__] and
then somebody told me like what the hell
I can't top a [__] NFL football
player well I mean it's just you know
you just had bad timing it was bad
timing yeah yeah yeah we would have
helped each other with our
disabilities my mental disabilities
right that's right you know let me ask
you this what do you do now cuz the
podcast you have another podcast so what
happens to the to the other podcast you
know not today pal is your new one with
Rob pajama pants before and so Tom
sigura and Christina P were fans of
pajama pants which was like so weird we
had like 10,000 listeners a week we were
like this tiny little podcast but this
like small and mighty we called them our
panties and like we had so much fun
doing that podcast because we were just
idiots and we and it you know me
Rob and our other Co CM G are all so
different and but so much love for each
other and it was silly and fun but you
know we weren't making a ton of money
from it and then when I moved to Austin
and then Rob moved to Austin and then
Cass was still in La like you know over
Zoom like you said like it's hard to get
a good it takes
forever I was going to quit so many
times yeah and you know know and just
things kind of clicked here and there
and not that it's like Becca's podcast
but you know we have a lot of people out
there who are just really loyal and love
the podcast and help the podcast and
spread the word great interview too I
know I mean I'm just like I I've learned
I've gotten better because I think in
the beginning like some of my friends
would be interviewed and like schwartzon
or Bobby Lee and they'd go don't
interrupt me you're interrupting me I'd
keep it in there I go sorry I I don't I
don't know what I'm doing
Sor right I just was like so you learn
that you learn to listen a little more
yeah um I don't get as nervous anymore I
figure you know um we're going to have a
good conversation we're going to you
know figure it out yeah we just sat down
we didn't even you didn't even say let's
go we were just talking no we've been
talking
for a half an hour holy [__] yeah we
don't even have that long to go isn't
that great no but bummer Becca's like
get me out of here um so so so anyway so
when that when PJ pants was kind of like
you know this is just not doing anything
for anyone and it's just the chemistry
is not what it was when we were all
together in a room Tom and Christina
were then expanding their um ymh Studios
Network um their podcast Network and
wanted to bring Rob on and then Rob was
like well I want Jamie to do the show
with me so that's where not today pal
came from and it's you know Rob and I
have a very unique experience like that
we share together which bonds us very
deeply but like has nothing to do with
our relationship today and so not today
pal is about you know him usually just
making me very uncomfortable and me
reacting to it like what does he make
you uncomfortable about what do you get
uncomfortable with I actually don't get
uncomfortable I'm a good sport I think
you know he just likes to they make fun
of
me um yeah they make fun of me a lot
what do they make fun of you about
cutter takes pictures of me meditating
and sends it to him and then they make
fun of me um they he likes to show me
pictures of me and ex-boyfriends and
talk about it like yeah but who are some
of your other ex-boyfriends well he
likes to talk my ex-husband a lot which
I don't well that's it was an agent
right he was my manager yeah he was your
manager yeah can we not talk about him
he gets too much air time you brought it
up I did now we're yeah I don't want to
talk I don't even remember his name
don't even say it does it start with at
a
his last
name first name okay so I was right I
mean it starts with an A yeah so so does
the word [__] that's right that's
right I mean if you want to a lot of
things start with that yeah that's for
sure a lot of things do do you miss what
do you miss I wish we could just do one
week of filming right now like right now
right because of just
like
my awareness of like the world and what
that was and what we were a part of and
like who I just wish I could experience
it like one episode give me one episode
right now like just drop me back in for
a coup what would the episode be
about good question um the family some
sort of internal struggle with the
family so a family heavy one um I always
loved moments when Meadow and Tony got
quiet together and it was all our scenes
when we would get quiet together the
dialogue would actually be really
limited it would just be these like
heavy like pregnant pauses and he Jim
was the type of scene partner where it
felt like he was there and his only
intention was to make me as good as I
could be wow and it had nothing to do
with him every time I work with him I
felt like his sole purpose was I'm going
to make you I'm I'm going to help you
give your best [__] take Jamie yeah
did you feel the same way like I'm Jim
Jim I'm going to make you as good as you
can be definitely didn't feel that way
but I more was like just watching a
really amazing that's when you know you
have it when you're so confident in
yourself as a as a performer that you
just want to make the other person it
had nothing to do with his confidence
cuz he was actually not he wasn't he was
insecure oh my God yes what would he do
like I doing another take fck what the
[__] am I what's the [__] line no he
would question himself like there would
be moments where he'd be like I [__]
suck but but I appreciated that because
I've had those thoughts but I didn't say
them out loud because I don't want
anybody to know that I think I suck he
was confident enough to say it out loud
oh I would I yeah yeah you know what I
mean so yes I guess there was a
confidence there but it was I think it
came more from him deeply caring deeply
deeply caring he was an exceptional
human being i' I've had that while I'm
working like I'm starting a scene and I
just I'm like God please cut please cut
I want to say cut right now I'm not
going to because I can't but this sucks
and I'm not into it and I well you
better get into it cuz you got another
three minute scene here going so okay
[__] it and then you just turn it on and
then he's like we can use the last half
of that I'm like that's what I thought
burn the first half burn the [__]
first half well I think that's why I'm
like would love to work with you because
I think that in TV it's so fast-paced
now that it's so hard to like unless
you're in a show for a couple years to
like get in a rhythm with people and
feel so safe with them to be able to
play like that like you and I have a
chemistry in a report in a relationship
where like if I work with you I would
feel so safe to do that and I just when
you're guest starring or even like
pilots and this it's so fast it's so
hard to be able to find that just to
jump into something and you don't really
know someone and it's a little
intimidating just it's just to got the
nerves you got this whole thing but when
you connect with someone that you just
look at and they're like hey let's let's
do this you want you want and and
they're just cool they want to run it
they want to play with you they want to
do this you know and just you know I
have I've had some of those um
relationships where they could say or I
could say because we were close enough
where I'd look at him and I Go Again
love it you I just love it say it again
cuz I got her back and then Tom would do
the same with me or whatever but you
have to be have if you don't know the
person you go do that again they're like
what the [__] [__] you what the [__] you
telling me but if you know the person
like you're like hey man you know cuz
we're in the moments and stuff and if
you see me and you're like hey you know
just [__] just don't throw I th I
like curve balls I like people playing
with me let me do hey let me say that
line again take it back just take it
back to your line real quick and then
I'm gonna say three in a row like that
what the [__] are you doing what the
[__] are you doing
love it and and you know what I mean and
you don't and it's not some people like
no no I want to just go right through
the you know yes just getting the
moments getting the moments and and not
um and just trusting that's nice it's
nice to have a partner like that cuz you
don't always get that no no everybody
wants to prove themselves I'm a great
actor I'm I'm like okay I just I don't
care how great you think you are I want
to get a great performance so it's on
that camera and it could last a lifetime
and you really like look you can't
always
that but right right you try sometimes
but get what you
need yeah I'm done go ahead deep that
was rolling stone I I'm aware uh I
forgot what I was goingon to say oh like
you know you can't always care about the
story you're at least I haven't always
like cared about the story that I'm
telling and sometimes when you're in it
you don't think about the story that
you're telling
but I would like like I think the dream
right is to get to a point where you're
you feel passionate about the stories
you're telling yeah I could see you
directing really yeah why couldn't you
direct I don't know are you do you do
you know how to read a lot of
responsibility I like show up and go
home here's the thing I don't want to
care about all the people but look if
you're directing TV or something or if
you want to direct a a movie I mean I
think people nowadays it's just it's
it's about the Angles and it's about
this and it's all about the story if you
have a great story it really directs
itself so you know you have a crew that
I just see you talking people respecting
you and you know being able to talk to
actors and I just think you'd have fun
yes it one my kids are young yeah yeah
yeah because it is exhausting it there's
nothing I loved popping in and out at
Albuquerque doing my scenes and then
going back from Austin like that was so
you want to work a couple days a week
and then you know be with your family or
just you know watch Bravo yep that's
what you want to unless unless I'm
feeling like I
am
like vibrating from like the work that
I'm doing like if it feels like I'm
growing and I'm getting better and I'm
challenging myself and this feels
amazing which it does even when you work
two to three time days of episode for
sure but I I it's been a minute since
I've had that like
that feeling yeah that feeling is hard
to get it is You've Lost That Loving
Feeling I haven't lost it I long for it
you long for it I I it'll come again
it'll come again it'll come again what
do you talk about on the podcast is it
really just everything like you're
saying I mean can you you get personal
oh yeah do you cry not on not on not
today pal not today pal you don't cry
there's no crying
no no it's a it's a
light people oh it's only 30 minutes
it's 30 minutes and where can they find
this Spotify yeah anywhere you
Shopify wherever the kids are doing all
those things yeah wherever you find
podcast you get that's great let me ask
you a a really personal question great
not like there hasn't been personal
questions today now it's not a personal
but like me I would like every time I
have something wrong with me or it's
this or a bulging disc or this or I look
online mhm and I go down rabbit holes
and it's not good that's why I go to
Zach
do.com you know real doctors no but I I
I will sometimes do that so if you know
if I had a God forbid a tumor or
something I would go what what's how
long can you live with a tumor uh how
long can you live with a tumor if it's
in your neck how long can you know what
I mean I'll just go down these things is
Ms something that people can live long
lives because I remember my friend his
mom had Ms when I was young and she had
it for like 40 or 50 like 50
years yeah when I was diagnosed uh and I
don't know if every neurologist would
say the same but I'm very appreciative
that the man that diagnosed me said
there's no reason to think that you
can't live a very healthy and long life
like this isn't a death sentence you
know modern medicine has come a long way
and ways of supporting and slowing down
the progression of the disease and it's
you know it's still very individual um
it's
still I have good days and bad days in
that like I can still do all of the same
things which is why I'm very confident
working like I don't feel like I'm going
to wake up one day and be like guys I
can't really
walk it's not that it's how I feel
internally is my good days or bad days
which look we all have that I can push
through and some days I don't have to
push through as much um
um I think where I get the most sad
sometimes is like man this this could be
forever for the rest of my life that I
have to live with this that's what
that's where I can get a little sad like
it's gonna it's going to be a little
hard forever probably yeah but I mean
with technology and the way things are
moving who knows I mean why couldn't
they why aren't they able to reverse it
I mean surprised they haven't been able
to do that yet and Alzheimer's and all
these things are so tragic it's like
we're waiting we're waiting for that you
know and when it h it could I think it
will happen I do too I really do I do
too and um I do too it'd be magical I do
too I think you have to always have hope
and it's not false hope because it's
it's not like we're in the [__] 1700s
and you don't know what the hell's going
on I have a lot of Hope but I think that
I have learned that
that it's better to not think about that
too much because it can take me so far
away from what it is
now it the the more accepting I am
getting in the
now the less pressure I feel about it
yeah you don't want it to consume you
you're like hey I can't well they always
say you know if you can't control
something if you can't change something
shove
it if you can't change or control
something shove it because it's not you
can't do anything responsibility I can't
when that comes I do the best I can to
take care of myself the best way
possible I I you look like honestly
great I was just going to like your arms
your legs look like muscular and I I
work out look you don't look 42 I swear
to God if I had a gun in my head 42 look
like I can show you people that are 42
and you know I look I appreciate what
you're saying thank you I think you
honestly if I had to guess I go oh she's
probably third
33 well cuz you're what do you have Ian
skin cream what is that what skin cream
Ian what is it called Avan is that water
I think I've used it's water sorry uh I
I don't know what skin cream I have on
it's just some moisturizer I don't have
makeup on though I'm not a makeup you
don't have makeup I'm not a makeup gal
Becca I me do you you have makeup no I
have more on than she does I have some
concealer she has concealer she is
nothing you have nothing never I'm not a
makeup person but like that's because of
your
genetics I don't know you have like Jew
in you I'm a Jew and you have something
else Cuban Cuban that I you know Greek
the what there you go little
ashkanazi well we all have ashkanazi
we're all little ashkanazi little
asanagi um I could talk to talk to you
forever about those about about
everything about being ashkanazi about
being ashkanazi is cutter is the
opposite of Jew he's not a Jew cutter is
not a Jew not a Jew though he acts like
a Jew he is Larry David my hus I thought
you gonna say something that might
insult the Jewish race but you did would
never my husband is Larry
David like he for instance like him and
Rob iser are very close which I love
they have their own separate
relationship he sent rob a picture the
other day of him with splattered shorts
and it just said done with urinals bro
because oh my God like that's him like
like or he'll just walk in a room and be
like shouldn't eaten that burrito and
then just like walk out I do that yeah
that's why I love you see yeah I do that
[__] or he'll just like walk in and be
like other kids will be doing like it
never ends and then just keep walking
never ends that's his famous quote only
thing going to go on his Tombstone it's
that did you ever see
did you did you ever see the uh curb
your enthusi uh Curb Your Enthusiasm
episode with the effeminate 10-year-old
kid who goes up to Larry and goes what
are you looking at Larry and Larry goes
oh I'm looking about look at these
things about this writing about Hitler
he goes what's a Hitler and he goes well
he was a very bad man you know he did a
lot of bad things oh what's that oh that
right there that's a swastika and he
goes oo I like it he goes you like you
like the swan the he goes yeah goes this
way and that way and this way and this
way yeah can I get one for Christmas he
goes yeah I don't think the Jews would
appreciate that he goes get a life
Jew it's so ridiculous and so funny that
my uncles and everybody were all Jews we
all laugh at it cuz it's like the kid
doesn't get it what's a what's a
Hitler's swasa I don't know what that is
I like it though it's cool it was just
really funny oh that's can we air that
or we get in trouble of course not they
show I'm not offend are you offended no
but I'm a Jew yeah but I'm a
Jew um what does offend you what do you
find
offensive being unnecessarily rude to
people
I yeah I no everyone's dealing with [__]
very aware I always give people passes
I'm really sensitive to to everyone I
understand that I have no idea what
you're dealing with but I still do not
think it's ever an excuse to be [__]
rude yeah like people in the restaurant
going excuse me where's our [__] meal
no exactly there's no matter what no
reason to be rude you can be down you
can be somber you can you can remove
yourself you can excuse yourself but
there's never an excuse to be [__]
rude
yeah I agree with you on that yeah it's
it's sometimes you want to be like you
know I when somebody's rude at you
that's
different yeah oh yeah I mean you got to
stand up for yourself would you rather
have someone say all right now try to
keep a straight face here okay somebody
you have a choice and they're serious
when they say this they cut you off by
going
quiet
or shut
up or
sh which bothers me
or a
snap what's the first one what's what's
the one thing I have mine that I'd be
like okay I'm okay with that which one
am I okay with well out of all of them
what's the what's the worst and what's
the One Snap is the worst snap's the hey
can't do it send a chill up my spine sh
I can I guess deal with is okay but you
know what mine is I don't mind when
someone says shut up quiet you don't
mind it it's kind of just funny CU I say
it to people too I go people would be
talking when I'm walking by driving I go
quiet and they go huh what am he say I
always say it I always say you know the
only time I get actually kind of pissy
at people is when I play Settlers of
Katan ooh I've never I have that game
and I've never played it we should play
that people so many people have told me
about that it's called Katan love yes I
love Katan I play it on my phone maybe
or isn't there a game called
raw not familiar the sun god
raw that sounds like a nerd game Katana
have that downstairs I love it it's it's
a little difficult to understand right
yes but once you get it it's it's good
yeah yeah I think it's time for [__]
talking with Jamie ly Sigler let's do it
I'm looking at my little face behind
your left shoulder by the way I didn't
realize that
you made you made the wall I made the
wall yeah made the Montage where are I
don't see I see you yeah you don't age
that's pathetic really now it's making
me question if I should go back to the
side
part hair let me see well you look
elegant there right now you look like a
girl next door what I'm going to get
into my elegant era I'm going to go back
go back to Elegance please whatever you
were doing go back to that got it not it
all right chit talking uh patreon.com
inside you Leanne what is your all-time
favorite TV theme
song Beverly Hills 902 and0 theme
song I I use this one you know what mine
is give me a break cuz I shall need one
give me a break n Carter give me a break
n Carter of course love that love it
finally found where I Bel
long wow give me a break you don't know
that do you I remember the show but I'm
not remembering to play it you know you
guys yeah I'm going to play it cuz you
guys are looking at me and when you hear
it you're going to be like wait a minute
that's give me I just like that good
electric guitar of Beverly Hills 92
[Music]
and0
yeah all right here we go give me a
break give me a
bre give me a
bre
[Music]
there's something about a synthesizer
look I know you share my love of 80s
music my wedding band was an 80s was
this um Spazmatics like amazing I
there's something about a
synthesizer and a voice like NE Carter
that just feels like home it does it
does it feels like you're home I
actually said that before cuz somebody
asked a question like that recently and
I came up with n Carter again that's the
second time wow big NE Carter fan I'm
sticking with it I love it I love that
show Raj tell me about your worst
haircut never had one it was on a set I
was doing this movie in the Dominican
Republic and
um the hairdresser was old
school and um they wanted more like
volume my hair and so we had like come
up with like maybe let's put some
extensions and he was like no I have an
idea I'm going to cut layers and when I
say cut layers there were like at the
top of my head all the way down to where
they had to fly someone in to put
extensions in my hair because of how
much he ruined my head did you
cry
uh
no no liar no I didn't cry that's crazy
yeah I think I cried cried when they
shaved my head for the first time really
yeah tell me about that that weird see
how long you had a shaved head for a
long time right I just I just was
nervous cuz I'm like they're going to
fire me I've got this weird bump it's my
occipital bump you thought they were
going to fire you cuz you had a bad well
I wasn't as as pretty as the rest of the
cast so I was kind of like you know I
thought odd man out it was a very C you
know very beautiful cast so I just
thought they'd fire me but um it turned
out you got a good Dum yeah uh who's the
coolest member DJ Kento ask a member of
the y MH Studio family oh God that's so
hard to pick I love Christina yeah I
love her she's like big mommy energy she
calls everybody Mommy and she's just
loving she's really supportive and
loving I love her Jessica B what's your
favorite piece of clothing you own and
why a cashmere sweater from the row cuz
it was from the row cuz it was like
thousands of dollars jeez L then I got
it a sample sale but still it just feels
expensive when I wear
it give me your best impression of
anybody you do impressions of even if
it's your mom I don't do Impressions how
would for this reason how would you how
would you if you were your mom how would
you be your mom
angry as a child as you're when you're a
child there were no words they were
being things
thrown and fists flying really your mom
was a Smacker big
time
there was no words I'm telling you it
was just a it was a it was like a out of
nowhere cross cross the face cross the
back you never saw it coming golden days
when parents could hit their kids I know
my Lane I don't I don't mean that like
hit their kids but an occasional butt
smack no people used to hit their kids
yeah thank you that's how it went thank
you yep Carrie B I also have MS I'll be
at the primary Progressive form and I'm
curious as to what your process is to
keep yourself healthy and able to get
through such long work days like is
there something in particular I don't go
to lunch with the crew I eat lunch in my
trailer which is a bummer to save your
strength y just a rest just a rest I
don't go out after work I go I just I'm
kind of when I'm working it's just work
and then home and I don't hang out as
much um not even to say because I would
have the energy but just to conserve if
I needed
um yeah and I just I asked for help more
I'll ask I'll be like yeah I'll ask for
a chair I'll ask for my trailer closer
or a van um and when you realize like
it's not that big of a deal and then
people start to get it I will say I just
joined this board um called the one and
four Coalition which is like um
basically just trying to educate all
different areas within this business
about people with
disabilities and a lot of Productions
are now going to start hiring like
disability coordinators so that first ad
wouldn't have to have that conversation
like the people in Big Sky figured it
out as we went along but now there'll be
somebody that could literally just be
like this is what you're going to need
for so actors you know crew members
everyone yeah I like that and then you
don't have to feel like oh I'm asking
even though you're it's not a you
shouldn't have to feel that way but this
is somebody who will take care of your
needs that's right I like it lastly gent
T her first interview was the reason I
became a patron of inside of you please
tell her that I said thank you for
sharing her story about her Ms diagnosis
as someone like myself who who this year
was tested for several neurological
conditions it was a scary time because
of her I felt that I was truly not
alone that's very sweet it makes me
emotional because that's like but that's
the exchange that I'm getting too
because I when I talk about it I don't
feel I feel less alone I when I share I
and get messages like that it reminds me
because that's you know that's what we
all want to feel right it's human right
it's a great thing about being a human
being when other people act like human
beings and yeah um well if you ever need
anything from me I'm here I know
seriously I know I mean go go to Becky
Becca first well obviously no I'm
kidding I'm kidding obviously no you
could honestly ask me for anything I'd
be there in a heartbeat I know you would
I adore the Versa I love you I I don't
want to bother you why would but I just
called you one day and say hey just you
would make me so happy I would yeah I
wouldn't if I
didn't was that the tree that was a
ghost you have ghosts in here mhm of
Halloween past oh wow yeah um I forgot
what I was gon to say what's your
favorite horror movie by the way I loved
all Freddy Krueger when I was a kid yeah
but a lot of them are terrible but
there's a few good ones the first one's
great the the Dream Warriors was great I
remember I remember so you know remember
Blockbuster is a thing I remember Friday
night my dad dad took me to Blockbuster
and I got Sleepaway Camp and I watched
it by myself Angela and I couldn't get
over at the end when you saw the penis
when they show penis give way to give it
away okay no it's 30 it's 40 years old
if you haven't seen it tough [__] but
sleep away camp if you haven't seen it
it's a doozy mean what scared me most
was the penis like that's what really
freaked me the freeze frames on her face
at
the have you seen it sleep away Kate oh
my God it's so bad but so good so bad
but so good um I adore the crap out you
this was great I knew it would be thanks
for being here I hope it was what do you
mean you hope it was I don't know I just
want to be invited back you'll come back
whenever you want to come back if you
feel like you want to say something you
come back okay that's it
okay all right see you later love
you epic epic that's all I'll say Jamie
I love you I think uh you're wonderful
human being and you spread joy to many
people and you give them hope and uh
your
honesty and um it just is
admirable so thank you and your talent
don't forget your talent and your beauty
and your intellect all that stuff uh
guys again if you like the podcast and
you said hey not bad um write a review
follow us on the handles at inside you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook at
inside you pod on the Twitter and join
Patron support the podcast by joining
patreon and you give back patreon.com
inside of you everything helps let's
give the shout outs you ready for this
Ryan I am all right here's the shout
outs to my lovable patrons and uh here
we go Nancy delicious Leah and Kristen
little Lil Lisa Yukiko Yukiko can you
hear me Yuko you're the best Jill e
Brian Henning camp Nico P Robert B Jason
Weaver Sophie M Raj C Joshua D Jennifer
N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B Mike E Elon
supro 99 Mo Santiago M Chad W lean P
hope you're feeling better Leanne matd s
Belinda n Dave Hall hello Dave it's Dave
Hall I love my Dave H couldn't live
without him Sheila G Brad d
Ray tab of the te Tom n Talia M Betsy D
Ranna C Cory K Deb Nexon Michelle a
Jeremy C Brandy D Joanie B Joey M Eugene
and Leah Corey Angela F Maddie s Mel s
Christine s Eric H Shane R Andrew M
Amanda R Jen B Kevin e Stephanie K Jerel
jam and J lean J's here Luna R Mike F
Stone H Kayla stay wild moonchild oh I
will Brian L Kendall L Cara C Jessica B
Kyle F Marisol P Kayley J Brian a Ashley
F Marian Louise L Romeo B Frank B J T
Nikki L April RM Derek N jdw
orlp Ginger Insomniac huh Ginger I know
who you are Rachel D lur L hi
lorai thanks for all your support I
really appreciate you Melissa too
Melissa H Nicholas W and Stephanie and
Evan you guys rock
patreon.com inside of you um that's it I
I just want to say I met some of you uh
at this live podcast and it was very
nice of you to come up uh so like uh
Anna ryes the banana was there yeah uh
Angelica was there Elon Supremo Elon
Supremo was there uh I met Nancy D I met
Raj C uh 99 more who I believe his name
is Sydney yeah there's all there's a lot
of patrons there met all of you and it
was very nice thank you yeah you guys
rock they love Ryan it was very nice
they love Ryan it was very neat you're
lovable that was nice from the Hollywood
Hills in Hollywood California I'm
Michael Rosen bomb I'm Ryan T still
little way to the camera we love you
guys thank you and of course be good to
[Music]
yourself